Let's say we have a magnetic
field that's coming out of the
right side of the screen.
And it's not just along the
screen, it's actually three
dimensional.
So it's going above the
screen, below, but the
direction of the magnetic
field is from the
right to the left.
Let me just draw that.
And I'm not going to draw a
bunch of the field vector
arrows because that'll just
take up a lot of valuable
space on our-- so that's the
vector magnetic field.
It's down here, too.
If I could, I would draw it
above your screen and below
your screen.
But it's coming from the
right to the left.
And then in that magnetic
field I
have an electric circuit.
I won't draw the whole
circuit right now.
I'll do that in a second.
But let's say I have--
part of the electric
circuit is a loop.
And the loop looks like this.
I'm trying to draw
it carefully.
So that we can-- because I think
a careful drawing will
be more useful in
a second than an
uncarefully drawn drawing.
So let's see.
So it's a loop.
You can almost-- you could
imagine taking a paper clip
and putting it into
this shape.
Oh, that's good enough,
I think.
And I have a current going
in this direction
in this paper clip.
So this is the positive,
that's the negative.
So the current is
going like that.
Current is going in
a loop like that.
The current's coming out
of this end, it's
coming into this end.
And let's say that loop of--
it could be a paper clip or
anything-- let's say
that it can rotate.
And that's important.
What's going to happen?
Well, my magnetic field is
coming in this direction.
The current is going
down here, up here.
What's going to be the net
force of the magnetic
field on this loop?
Well, let's try it out.
And it turns out it's going to
be a different magnitude at
different points
of the current.
So here.
And we don't worry about-- all
we're worried about right now
is direction.
And then maybe a little
intuition of the magnitude.
So we know that the force of the
magnetic field is equal to
the current times the
length vector cross
the magnetic field.
Well, what would be the force of
the magnetic field on this
segment of wire?
We could call this L.
And that L goes in the same
direction as the current.
Well, let's see.
Current is just a scalar,
but L is going down.
Magnetic field going
to the left.
Cross product.
Cross product, I take my right
hand, put my index finger in
the direction of the current,
or in the direction of L,
because that's the first term
of the cross product.
So that's the index finger.
So my index finger goes down,
because that's the direction
of the current.
And then my middle finger-- and
remember, you have to do
this with the right hand.
If you do it with the left hand,
you're going to get the
opposite result.
And now my middle finger is
going to go in the direction
of the field.
So let me point my
middle finger.
My middle finger is
going to go in the
direction of the field.
I keep having to look
at my own hand.
And then my other two fingers
are just going to do what they
need to do.
So that's my third finger.
That's my pinky.
And then what is my
thumb going to do?
What is my thumb going to do?
Well, my hand-- that's
my hand.
This is what my hand is doing.
I'm pointing downward.
And my palm is kind of
pointing at my body.
So what is my thumb doing?
I know it's hard to see.
This is my middle finger
right here.
So my thumb is on the other
side of this drawing.
And my thumb is pointing
downwards.
I hope you see that.
And you try it with
your own hand.
So my thumb is pointing
downwards.
So the direction of the force
created by the magnetic field
on this current is going
to go downward.
So let me draw that.
So the force vector--
I'll do it in this
orangey brown color.
The force vector on this segment
of the wire is going
to be going down.
Now what about this segment
of the wire?
Well, think about it.
This segment of the wire, the
L vector-- this L vector--
It's parallel to the magnetic
field just in
the opposite direction.
And so when you take the cross
product-- remember, the cross
product is you're multiplying
the magnitude of the vectors
that are perpendicular
to each other.
But if this is the L vector
right here, there's no
component of it that it's
perpendicular to
the magnetic field.
So the magnetic field and the
current are in the same plane.
They're parallel.
They're not orthogonal at all.
There's no components of them
that are at 90 degrees.
So when you take the cross
product, you're going to see
that the net force on this
segment of the wire is 0.
And likewise on this segment of
the wire and this segment
of the wire.
Because they aren't in any
way perpendicular.
No components of them are
even perpendicular.
So fair enough.
So all we know right now is the
magnetic field is exerting
a downward force on this
side of our paper
clip or of our circuit.
Now what about this side?
Well, same thing.
Take the cross product.
If this is our L, L cross B.
So take your index finger
in the direction--.
So index finger goes
like that.
Your middle finger will go in
the direction of the field.
So your middle finger is going
to look something like that.
And then your other
two fingers are
going to be like that.
And what is your thumb
going to do?
And this has to be your
right hand to work.
Your thumb is going to
point straight up.
This is like the heel
of your thumb.
Your thumb is going to--.
I don't know if that's a good
drawing of a thumb.
But your thumb is essentially
pointing out of the page.
Middle finger in the direction
of the current, or in the
direction of our length.
Sorry, index finger in the
direction of the current.
Middle finger in the direction
of the field.
Thumb points out of the page.
Do that with your own right hand
and you'll see that the
net force of the magnetic field
on this segment of the
wire is going to be upwards.
Let me do it in a different
color just to get some
contrast.
So what's going to happen?
Assuming that this circuit
can rotate,
what's going to happen?
On this side there's
a downward force.
an upward force.
So the magnetic field is
actually exerting a
torque on this wire.
If you viewed this little dotted
line as our axis of
rotation, the whole coil is
actually going to rotate
around that line.
And so there's some force over
here, along this whole line
being applied downwards.
And it's actually perpendicular
to our moment arm.
If you remember what we had
learned about torque.
So it will actually exert all
of that force-- that force
times this distance
will be the torque
applied on this side.
And then likewise there's a
torque-- it's really the same
sign, in the same direction,
because here on the other side
of the arm it's pushing
upwards.
So they're not going
to cancel out.
They're both going
to reinforce.
And this whole coil
is going to be
turning in this direction.
Here it's going to be moving up
out of your video screen.
Here it's going to be moving
down into your video screen.
Now what happens?
I'm going to try to not run
out of time either.
So it's going to
start rotating.
So the left hand side's going
to go below the page.
The right hand side's going
to be above the page.
I want to draw some perspective,
that's why I'm
just drawing it bigger.
Maybe it looks like that.
Maybe my circuit starts
to look like that.
And I'll redraw my
axis of rotation.
So this is my axis
of rotation.
And on the way I drew it--
this part, the axis of
rotation is still in the
plane of our video.
But this part of the
coil is, you could
imagine it popping out.
I wish you had 3D glasses on.
It's popping out
of your screen.
This part is going
into your screen.
And the current is still going
in the same direction.
Current is going in that
direction there.
So using the same right hand
rule, on this side of the wire
the magnetic field is going
to be exerting a
net downward force.
But the torque is actually going
to be less because our
moment arm distance is going to
be like-- I want to draw it
with some perspective.
It's going to look something
like that.
So it's going to be going to the
left and behind the page
while the torque is still
just into the page.
So you would actually take the
component of the torque that's
perpendicular.
So there's some component of
the torque that's actually
perpendicular.
I don't want to confuse
you too much.
But you could imagine
the torque lessens.
Even though the net magnetic
force is the same, the
component of that force that's
perpendicular to your moment
arm, that lessens.
So there's still going to be
some torque that's going to be
causing it to rotate downwards
in that direction.
Sorry.
You know what?
I drew this wrong here.
We're pushing up on the right
hand side, we're pushing down
on the left hand side.
So the direction is going
to be like that.
Pushing up on the right hand,
down on the left hand.
So you're still going to be
doing the same thing here.
You are going to be
pushing up here.
But you're going to be pushing
up directly out of the page.
But that's not completely
perpendicular
to the moment arm.
So the component that is
perpendicular, that's actually
creating rotational torque,
that's going
to be a little less.
And then you could imagine that
all the way to the point,
the coil's going to keep
rotating with smaller torque.
At some point you'll be
looking at it head on.
So I can just draw it like
a straight line, right?
You can imagine.
This arm is on top and this
arm is behind it.
And at this point, what's
going to happen?
All the magnetic force on
this top arm is going
to be popping up.
It's going to be popping up out
of your page but it's not
going to be providing
any torque.
Because it's not perpendicular
anymore to your moment arm.
And likewise, on the bottom
behind this, if you could
visualize this, it would be
exerting a net downward force.
And that's also not going
to be helpful.
But maybe they have some angular
momentum so the wire
will still rotate.
But then when it still rotates,
what's going to happen?
And this is where I'll
leave you with a
little bit of a conundrum.
Actually, I don't want to go
over the Youtube limit, so I'm
going to continue this in the
next video and I'll show you
the conundrum.
See you soon.